- [Narrator] The MISSISSIPPI
RIVER is drying up.
Water levels are approaching record lows,
BARGES are getting stuck on sandbars
in unprecedented numbers.
Many ports and docks no
longer have water deep enough
for commercial boats to safely reach them.
And this is a problem
for the whole country.
- The MISSISSIPPI RIVER a lot of people
just think of it as this beautiful
large historic river in
the middle of the country,
but really it serves as
a transportation highway
for a lot of industry.
- [Narrator] The river is
a critical shipping route
for agriculture, oil
and building materials.
And the MISSISSIPPI WATERSHED
which includes all the
creeks, streams, and lakes
that feed into the MISSISSIPPI RIVER
is the largest in the US.
- Farmers in Iowa,
they harvest their soybeans
and they put them on
BARGES and send them down
to the port below New Orleans,
and then that's sent to China.
Chemicals are processed in Louisiana
and sent it up river to the Ohio
to factories in Pittsburgh.
The central part of this country
thrives in part on industry,
moving goods and services
up and down the river.
- [Narrator] October is traditionally
a month of low water on the Mississippi.
But this year, the rivers water levels
are approaching lows not seen since 1988.
- And if that's the case,
the river at certain points
is just gonna shut down
for commercial traffic.
- [Narrator] The water has gotten so low
that a shipwreck was exposed
along the banks of the river
in Baton Rouge, Louisiana
earlier this month.
Archaeologists believe it's sank in 1915.
In recent weeks, there
have been over 20 blockages
on the river and backups
of 1000s of BARGES per day.
- When a barge gets stuck on a sandbar,
it's a real expensive mess.
Another barge has to come,
you have to bring equipment
to remove that material
and put it in another barge
to the point where it will float enough
so that it can get off the sandbar.
- [Narrator] In some cases the TOWBOATS,
which pull dozens of BARGES each
have hit sandbar so hard
that the BARGES they're towing disconnect.
And that's dangerous for
bridges and other boats.
Riverboat cruises have also halted
due to low water levels.
Industry leaders say,
if water levels stay this
low or get even lower,
the tourism industry
will take a massive hit.
So what's causing the river to dry up?
- [Cameron] It just did not
get enough rain this year,
particularly in the
upper OHIO RIVER VALLEY.
Normally, this is hurricane
season in the south.
Some hurricanes will plow
into the United States
and then become enormous rainstorms
that go up into the OHIO RIVER VALLEY
and dump a lot of rain.
That didn't happen this year.
- [Narrator] And industries
that rely on the river
to transport goods don't
have many alternatives.
- It's not as though a farmer
can just run to the railroad
and that solves the problem.
The rail system is so pressed right now
and they've have labor shortage issues.
They have capacity issues
that they're running into.
- [Narrator] But sticking with the river
will be costly for farmers.
Normally, shipping along
the MISSISSIPPI RIVER
is the cheaper option.
But with fewer boats
and BARGES able to transport
goods prices have shot up.
For example, the cost of
sending a ton of corn,
soybeans, or other grains
from St. Louis to southern Louisiana
has jumped over 380% since October 2021.
The fall harvest season,
which usually peaks in October
is the busiest time for
agricultural products.
- If you can't get a rail line out,
your soybeans are just
sitting in an open field.
I mean, a lot of farmers
are hesitating to even harvest right now.
Let's say there are massive rainstorms
and your soybeans are
just sitting out there,
that could really, really
really be disastrous.
- [Narrator] This
disruption along the river
comes at a time when the war in Ukraine
has prompted huge demand
for American agricultural products.
- And farmers are very excited.
They can't get their stuff to market.
They can't get it to market.
Not easily and not cheaply.
- [Narrator] Over the last few weeks,
the U.S. COAST GUARD
has imposed restrictions
on the depth that
commercial boats and BARGES
can sit in the water,
and on the number of
BARGES that tows can pull.
Both actions are to try to stop BARGES
and boats from getting stuck.
But industry leaders say it's not enough.
- There's no real answer
except for the rain.
There's hope that
beginning around December,
rain will start to fall
in the OHIO RIVER VALLEY
to an extent where it'll start to bring
that water back down to the Mississippi
and things will get better.
If not, we're all in a lot of trouble.
(gentle light music)